how's it going rose - 45 we're back with
some more oculus we're gonna check out
some games and it's gonna be a mighty
good time
so John in John in well why don't you
come up ahead
first game it's boot up clone up [ __ ]
you oh god what is going on here okay
this is pretty [ __ ] cool oh my god
look at my hands yeah like it's sprained
well I can fly what the what I have a
jetpack
Oh alright let's go to the club yeah
what's up let me spray your [ __ ] let me
spray yeah I don't know what this does
but I'm doing it woah woah I'm tripping
out over here
what is that oh hey girl what's that
don't worry I don't know her name but I
have 3d snakes coming from my body oh
[ __ ] that Buddha is shooting lasers Oh
God Eddie let's make it out with me Oh
what the [ __ ] I'm so high up I'm so
[ __ ] high right now
oh my god it's making me motion sick no
I can't I can't I can't no boys should
sing this please okay I'm dead the beat
drop kid denied to be drugged alright
though I was pretty cool let's check out
another one though alright the next one
is called fire breather I'm pretty
excited about this one should be [ __ ]
cool
oh god watch what am i doing up
ha ha ha ah oh also my god I know I
should know that Chile taka hello why
does no one want to be friends with me
and why is the face melted off of all my
friends I don't understand
it's so weird to try these out like it
you can't explain I got my test
you really can't explain it I'm sorry
for doing something short but if I play
longer I get motion sickness so I hope
you both understand helix this looks up
it six [ __ ] up man
Oh God Lisa BAE what the [ __ ] that's
like where I used to live in Sweden
hello I got what that what I didn't mean
to click it I'm in a cinema oh you can
see a little tiny sparks and my Swedish
popcorn that looks all melted together
and [ __ ] and my Swedish soda but I can't
grab it I cockeyed all this is a
nightmare
alright let's let's play oh my god oh my
god this is so weird
who the [ __ ] are you lady Sims Oh
Oh motion sickness yay oh god oh god I
can't oh god I can't no nothing look oh
god not that ah what is happening
absolutely
I'm sorry no I can't I can't
Oh God we made it wow that was so good
oh my god again again please maybe you
want to get them coffee after this maybe
accepting
back to reality goddammit I suck I wish
I could play like these crazy ones but
like yeah curse it's my dad's fault all
right
play my dad cuz he gets real emotion
saying oh my god
that is so cool oh [ __ ] what am i oh I'm
so short - oh my god it's you hey guys
it's me that's not cute
that's a chi ho I would like to not die
please I'll talk to me I don't know if
you've read somewhere this is from that
it's from spirited away pretty much it's
an awesome movie if you haven't seen it
like what are you doing go watch it
right now
it's really cool next up Dino town shut
up [ __ ] I'm playing with the aquata
have my god ow all right here we go
dinah town take me there
my favorite tap whoa hey girl what's
wait what are you doing walking into me
are you blind
hello don't sass me girl don't sass me
hey what are you going now wait what the
hell how do you not see this the sign it
says everywhere
come on hi oh hi oh do you see the
dinosaur do you see the dinosaurs no
just me oh I might
I'm a bloody good weather head today
I'll bet he doesn't want to talk to me
oh god damn that is apatite Ratna nod
you're done those are my favorite I love
pretend I read in adenoids Oh what is
this this will have to be in and kill la
Souris because it has a lot of ankles
let's not get murdered by it ow ow hey
guys are you talking about the dinosaurs
oh god what the [ __ ] is he doing dad
it's our neighbor I don't understand my
god you know what I'll have to find us
the answer to this me [ __ ] okay he's
definitely blind you're excused sir
but the rest is [ __ ] dumb or the
arrow tells me to go here what goes on
oh my god alright be a nice t-rex damn I
am very bony and thin and you don't want
to eat me trust me trust me you yeah I
that that that all right you know what
you can meet me I'm probably eating my
beautiful face Oh God now oh well I bet
I was delicious so it's okay what is
this
catch catch but Darren up and fly ooh
nice ass yeah this is a dream come true
whoa
to infinity and beyond
go get Oh No oh my god it's oh yeah this
is awesome my god
oh gosh [ __ ] calm down there oh god the
motion sickness Oh God no thank you oh
boy that sure was a fun ride I did not
nearly throw up
thank you for play you are welcome for
playing me play this has been great I'm
gonna go and throw up somewhere what I
hope you enjoy watching I leave a like
if you did and I'll see you breasts in
the next video thank you for watching
stay awesome
I'll be right back